We've explored a few simpler methods
on how to deal with missing data.
Both deletion and
imputation are relatively easy to do.
However, we've seen where there can
be issues with either approach.
Now depending on the business analysis,
we could progress to more advanced
methods to deal with missing data.
And while this is beyond
the scope of the class,
I'll just mention a couple that
you can explore on your own.
The first is called multiple imputation.
This is where you do the imputation
process multiple times
using a method that will
predict the missing values.
Typically by using a regression
of other variables and
then adding in some random error.
With these multiple sets of data,
you create the analytical model
multiple times, and then basically
blend those models together.
As we've mentioned, this is an advanced
method and is fairly sophisticated.
But if our business question and
results could be significantly
off by using a simpler method,
you might want to explore this option.
Another advanced method is called
full information maximum likelihood.
Even the name is sort of intimidating,
right?
Here the missing values
aren't actually replaced, but
they're handled within
the modeling process itself.
This only works for
certain types of models and
will require special software
that can handle this methodology.
Again, both of these are beyond
the scope of the course, but
I wanted to make sure
you were aware of them.
For more information, you can find a few
links in the area below the video.